[Music]
[Applause]
Chris Mannix joining us Sports
Illustrated senior basketball writer all
right how did they pull this off and
nobody knew what was going on with uh
the Trailblazers and the Bucks
well the reality Dan is Milwaukee wasn't
really engaged with Portland until the
last week to two weeks uh you know the
Bucks they won 58 games last year they
felt pretty comfortable after the season
kind of nibbling around the fringes but
as the off season developed we saw
Giannis tentacumpo pretty pointedly note
that if this team doesn't do more to
improve or doesn't put itself in
position to be a championship Contender
for years to come he was going to look
elsewhere and I think that really
activated the Milwaukee Bucks front
office they had a piece that was
interesting in Drew holiday who Portland
doesn't necessarily want but can
certainly flip for other assets over the
next couple of weeks and months uh and
they had another team in Phoenix that
wanted to get in on the mix to to build
out some of its depth so this was not a
case where Milwaukee was talking to
Portland all off season long they just
got really uh interested in this mix
over the last two weeks and were able to
put it together
do you think Giannis if they didn't make
this move
was not going to sign that new contract
with Milwaukee
he most certainly wasn't going to sign
the three-year 169 million dollar
extension he's eligible for right now
he's eligible to sign that deal up until
October 23rd and and nobody believed he
was going to sign that he was going to
let see how this season played out and
go into next off-season where he would
have one year left on his deal and be
eligible to sign I believe a four-year
250 plus million dollar uh contract so
he was not going to sign the deal right
now he may still not sign that extension
right now but he and his team certainly
have something to think about over the
next three weeks I mean Giannis as you
know at this point is an unabashed fan
of Damian Lillard drafted him first at
the All-Star Game during the draft so
there's no doubt that Giannis wants to
play with Damian Lillard this is not a
situation where Lillard is a rental
lilives around for at least the next
three years probably four because that's
a player option at the back end of that
deal worth more than 60 million dollars
so the this is a guy Giannis can tie
himself to with a long-term contract and
I think there'll be serious
consideration given by Giannis and his
Camp to sign that extension now anybody
heard from Dame Lillard he had a site
set on Miami and now he'll end up in
Milwaukee
I mean just that he's you know his own
tweet was excited to be a buck excited
for the next chapter uh look Damian
Lillard wanted to play and live and
operate out of Miami there's no question
about that uh he liked the idea
certainly of living in Miami living on
South Beach but most important to Damian
Lillard the stage of his career is
winning if the Portland Trailblazers had
a team that could compete for a
championship Damian Lillard would stay
there he would have no problem living in
Portland for the rest of his playing
career Miami was Miami but it also had a
team that was coming off a finals
appearance it had ruthless competitors
in Jimmy Butler and Bam out of bio and
arguably the best coach in the NBA so
Damian Lillard solved that situation
said I want to play there as much as I
want to live there he certainly doesn't
want to live in Milwaukee as badly as he
wanted to live in Miami but the Bucks
give Lillard probably a better chance to
win multiple championships over the next
four years then Miami did Jimmy Butler
as great as he is is 34 years old the
Bucks don't or the heat don't have a lot
of talent right now down there around
him the Bucks Giannis is 28. Chris
Middleton in his early 30s they've still
got the Ageless Brooke Lopez on that
roster I mean that team is built to win
championships and I promise you that is
the most important thing to Damian
Lillard
I felt like Miami was almost at a
disadvantage because Dame wanted to go
to Miami and therefore Miami probably
was not giving a great offer or one that
would get Portland's attention how did
Miami for lack of a better description
screw this up
well they didn't go all in for Lillard
and the reasons for that you know could
be multitude you know maybe they didn't
believe that you know Lillard at 33
years old with 200 million left on his
deal warranted them to go all in maybe
they wanted to keep some of their powder
dry in case a player like Giannis or a
player like Joel embiid became available
over the next year two years Miami is
always in Star hunting mode and I think
look the heat believed that they were
the only game in town and the reality is
for a while they were right as I
mentioned the Bucks were not in this mix
for the better part of this offseason
the Raptors I see another team mentioned
they were not in this mix for the better
part of this off season for a while the
heat were operating from a position of
strength whether he got it wrong and
where I think majority of heat Twitter
and some members of heat media got it
wrong is that they just couldn't
conceive the idea that Joe Cronin
wouldn't do a d deal that would satisfy
Damian lill there was a belief almost
that Cronin and the Blazers should feel
lucky to get some combination of Tyler
hero and a couple of first round picks
the Blazers never operated that way they
didn't want Tyler hero they didn't they
believed they could do better than Tyler
hero in a couple of first round picks or
three first round picks whatever it may
be and whatever you want to feel about
DeAndre Hayden the guy's a 25 year old
18 point 10 rebound per game scorer as a
third option on a team last year this
guy's got room to grow so uh I think
where the heat got it wrong was that
they believed they were going to be the
only game in town leading into training
camp and that just did not turn out to
be the case Chris Mannix Sports
Illustrated senior basketball writer I
like what Phoenix did
you know they got rid of DeAndre ayton
from the standpoint of maybe he was not
going to be happy now you know he's even
further down on the totem pole with
Bradley Beal there uh and they added
some depth there
um
are they the team to beat out west now
well we have to see how it all comes
together right I mean we get really
excited about these super teams and
sometimes they work out and sometimes
they're like the 2000 what 12 Los
Angeles Lakers sometimes it's just you
never know how it's all going to come
together but
even though on paper I don't like the
eight and deal because Aiden's a really
talented guy and I would have loved to
have seen what Frank Vogel could do with
him Frank vogel's got a a rich history
of Reviving centers he did it with Roy
Hibbert in Indiana he got the most out
of Dwight Howard during his season in
Los Angeles so Frank Vogel I think would
have maximized the talents of DeAndre
but I get the deal right like they
needed NBA players incredible NBA
players to be part of that rotation
Grayson Allen he certainly one of them
he gives them a 40 three-point shooter
to play off all those guys Nasir little
I think is a good player Yusuf nurkic
certainly not the player DeAndre ayton
is but a serviceable guy to play in the
middle and someone that's really used to
setting you know crunching screens for
players as he'll be asked to do uh in
Phoenix so I get it from Phoenix's
perspective I do think they got deeper
uh whether they got better we'll we'll
see but they they prioritize depth in
this deal over maximizing the top end
Talent who do you uh put as the team to
beat this year right now Milwaukee it's
Milwaukee it's got to be I mean look the
the reason the Bucks have bowed out of
the playoffs over the last couple of
years whenever they've got in trouble in
the playoffs it's almost always been
half court offense I mean for all of
Drew holiday's marvelous talents uh he
is not an especially efficient half
court offensive player Damian Lillard
solves that problem he is a cure-all for
that problem he's got to step into that
lineup and have one of the most
devastating two-man games with Giannis
10pa that we're going to see in in the
NBA next season now people can say yeah
they lose something defensively and they
sure do I mean they're not going to be a
top five defensive team again but they
still have Giannis and Lopez on that
back line to clean up a lot of their
mistakes so I think they'll be okay or
good enough defensively and they're
going to be positively Dynamic
offensively they've still got some depth
there with Jay Crowder Pat coneden Uh is
in that mix Bob Beauchamp is still there
uh and they'll be in the mix to sign
guys after the trade deadline this year
I I just think they're not only the
favorite right now to win the East uh
they're the favorite to win the whole
thing good to talk to you Chris as
always glad you're fired up here talking
basketball during football season
he got it thank you Chris Chris Mannix
senior writer for sports illustrator